hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
treat them like the criminal
organization they are a conservative MP
says just stop oil protesters should be
arrested under terrorist laws
powering down the government confirms
they will be launching an energy-saving
campaign encouraging people to use less
gas and electricity
and could the melting polar ice cap
cause an underwater tsunami
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis a conservative MP has asked the
prime minister to treat one of Britain's
most high-profile environmental groups
like a terrorist organization Gareth
Johnson is the MP for Dartford and Kent
where the just stop oil group has
repeatedly blocked the M25 Motorway
causing disruptions for tens of
thousands of people prime minister's
questions the MP said the Environmental
Group should now be subject to much
harsher punishment
last month just stop oil clambered up
the dart from Crossing causing chaos for
days they then attacked artworks the M25
and anything else to cause misery and
Mayhem these people are not protesters
they are criminals
will the Prime Minister therefore
consider making just the oil a
prescribed organization so that they can
be treated as the as the criminal organ
they actually are
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the kind of demonstrations
we've seen recently disrupt people's
daily lives they cause Mass misery for
the public and they put people in danger
the police have our full support in
their efforts to minimize this
disruption and Tackle Reckless and
illegal activity the public order bill
will give them the powers they need and
I look forward to seeing the support
that that bill receives from every part
of this house
so if just stop oil could be prosecuted
like terrorist groups how would this
change environmental protests well we
are Sky's police commentator Graham
wetton to explain
it changes significantly the way the
police would deal with them their
actions their supporters anyone that
knows that they're going to take
um directs action in any time
means that everybody then is liable to
arrest so it changes the way the police
approach them if they do come out in the
street it also opens up an Avenue of
monitoring of the individuals and the
groups involved for their actions so it
does change significantly but for me
that's a very big step to take if
someone's arrested under a terrorism act
they can detain for far longer than
under a normal legislation of Police use
police and criminal Evidence Act so it
does change massively the way that
people have dealt with once they are
detained that they can actually be held
incommunicated for a longer period of
time so it does change massively the way
that police deal with it it's a
suggestion at the moment to prescribe
them so when you look at the definition
of what a prescriber or what terrorist
organization that is prescribed is it
does fit it I can see why people are
looking at it and thinking it fits it
for an organization to be prescribed it
has to fit certain criteria and I can
see why when you look at it in the
literal letter of the law the way it's
written they do actually fit partly um
description would be in a prescribed
organization but for me they haven't
gone far enough yet to reach that status
that category for me they're across
threshold when they actually start
causing harm to people actually injuring
people which they haven't got they're a
non-violent direct action group their
cause is just people understand climate
change but for me their tactics their
methods the leaders and the organizers
of the group actually push them towards
direct action and confronting the public
and alienated but the very big we need
on their side
okay well let's speak now to the
environmental campaigner Tina rothery
who's the co-founder of the nanas
against frackink group hi Tina thank you
so much for joining us now you've been
fracking in Le you've been protesting
excuse me against fracking in Lancashire
for more than a decade and you've
actually been arrested for demonstrating
so how did that play out did they keep
you detained for long were you charged
with anything what happened there
I've managed to escape without a
criminal record and a lot of the arrests
were just sort of spurious and dropped
later
um I've spent two terms in jail but only
you know for 12 hours and seven hours
but the point being that it's a
disruption to your life and also a huge
insult to who you are as a human being
and why you're doing what you're doing
you know they talk about the fact that
they would arrest us under this act in
order to stop the misery and Mayhem and
yet that's what we're trying to prevent
is the misery of Mayhem that will come
if we continue to degrade nature pollute
disguise throw sewage in our waterways
yeah these are the things and the only
thing I agree with them on is the fact
that we will need a law to stop protests
but that law would have to criminalize
those who are actually doing the harm
the fossil fuel companies the polluters
they're the ones who should be
criminalized there's a climate and
ecology Bill going through now and if
that gets through then that would stop
people like me having to blockade trucks
stop people throwing soup at Van Gogh
because what we're doing would be
protect not protected it wouldn't be
necessary because the stuff that causes
harm would be illegal as it should be
you look at things that the industries
themselves
have in their favor there's um an energy
treaty that allows you know you know a
company in Britain to sue uh Slovenia
for Banning fracking because they'll
lose profit we don't have tools like
that and you're always seeking to do is
protect our families our children in the
future you know what people do people
tend to get attention yeah you know
we're not whatever this comes up it's
always
the argument is listen we get the
message we get the message and what
you're saying but how people say it is
the problem I mean do you think that
some groups are now going too far and
although the Prime Minister did stop
sort of agreeing to the move he warned
that the protests had course as you just
pointed out Mass misery for the public
and that they put people in danger do
you think that the problem is that the
way they go about doing this is too much
now
so you say they've got the message did
they you know what are they doing you
know how have they responded and in what
way have they got the message you know
because it doesn't show they would say
that they're doing that they're working
towards it you know we've just had cop27
wrap up our government had these
policies in place they would say we
understand and we're working towards it
well right now the people I would say
were the criminals are the people in the
energy sector who are overloading our
bills and the money still goes into new
fossil fuel Investments I mean that's
ridiculous so no they haven't heard it's
not loud enough
I'm sure they would refute the claims
that they're um criminals but how much
public opposition how much public
support do you have you seen for your
protests and um
which way
oh yes support from our community from
the residents from you know the people
locally from our Council who rejected
the planning um but of course
Westminster overturned that and didn't
listen to our Council or us what just
stop oil do is not what I in the same
way that maybe I would protest but I
look at these young people and I
understand their desperation you know
when we were young we were growing up
with a whole future ahead of us what are
they growing up with with this fear and
uncertainty and pollution do you think
that there's a danger that if this does
go through that there could have a
chilling effect that people won't
possibly protest if there is the chance
of criminal
charges you know what is a democracy
without protest can it even call itself
a democracy if it doesn't permit it you
know I think there's a big danger and
this is a step too far this is a step
way too far to jump straight to a law
that would criminalize mean and people
like me from saying no I will not have
this it will harm my grandchild so I
must raise my voice so and I would
imagine then that if you look at things
like union strikes when does it then
also apply to them standing out there
protesting for their rights okay this is
going to completely change the whole way
that we operate as a society in a
democracy and it turns it into what
would look a bit more like a I don't
know a dictatorship okay thank you so
much for talking to us we're gonna have
to leave it there Tina but really thank
you so much for talking about okay thank
you so much for your time thank you
foreign other climate news today the
government has confirmed it will be
launching an energy-saving awareness
campaign to reduce the amount of gas and
electricity we use it comes as off gem
announced the energy price cap will once
again rise to over 4 000 pounds in
January the chancellor says people need
to change their behavior when it comes
to managing energy usage
scientists on a research vessel in
Antarctica have watched the front of a
glacier disintegrate and create an
underwater tsunami as tall as a house
now internal tsunamis are an important
factor in Ocean mixing this affects life
in the ocean temperatures at different
depths and how much ice the ocean can
melt Glaciers are set to carve more as a
result of global warming potentially
causing more underwater instability
and new analysis from the think tank
energy and climate intelligence unit
says Farmers without solar panels could
be missing out on billions of pounds of
extra funding it's thought about 80
percent of England's Farms don't
currently have solar power and the group
says switching to renewable energy could
be essential for the survival for some
Farm businesses now if you have a
question about climate change that you
want to be answered send them all via
this QR code on the screen and we will
try to answer as many as possible on the
climate Show with Tom Heep over the
weekend and just a reminder you can
watch Tom's show on Saturdays and
Sundays at 3 30 in the afternoon and
then again at 7 30 in the evening
but for now for me Kimberly Leonard
thank you so much for watching we'll see
you soon
[Music]